roller derby what's better than a whole
gang of girls down and knocking you over
I love rollerskating because it's
basically having cars on your feet we're
going into a ring with a bunch of buff
women who are gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
us this is a terrible idea
[Music]
what do I know about roller derby it's a
sport we're tough ladies push each other
for an hour while skating you put wheels
on your feet get someone in the shoulder
they fall you stand up it's good man
feels good this seems like it was
imagined in a 1980s science fiction
novel it sounds like a sport I'd love to
watch but today we're doing it and we do
it with the Derby dolls the most famous
group of girls who push over other girls
roller derby is a full-contact sport and
it involves two teams on the track who
field two jammers one from each team
every opposing blockers hips that she
passes is a point skate and turn left
and you don't fall you can follow but
just get up right away the Derby dolls
are the Derby dolls a team are the Derby
dolls believe how work we are a women's
bank track League based in Los Angeles
we have four home team bike crew
sirens tough cookies and mighty and
varsity brawlers which is possessive
ever so we are gonna teach you first to
fall small some basic stop myself down
how to skate the track how to hit people
that's a fun part of Derby I've probably
played the most contact sports out of
the try guys but this is the first time
I've played against only women I have
the structural integrity of uncooked
pasta my body is just waiting to crumble
and blow off into wind injuries are kind
of common in roller derby it is a
full-contact sport actually enjoy
getting beaten up like I really like
physical pain I'm getting married so I'm
very concerned about all of me my fiance
told me not to do this video not because
she cares about my face because she
cares about that wedding professor
Jaeger I've never skated before is this
a good place to start um well I have a
better idea for you guys
there any tips don't fall great okay
okay
[Music]
Oh
on your side
[Music]
and we're supposed to like bump people
like this um so after an hour of
learning at his skate now it's time to
go to a ramp where the Derby dolls are
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of me and my
friends but so everybody's basically
doing the exact same thing to get on the
track you're slightly athletic I've been
bowled
so in two days we're gonna go from
beginner to no skating experience to
playing a roller derby match how [ __ ]
are we 10.5 that's pretty good I mean
I'm gonna be 10 bad survive more fun
office kill five more [ __ ] than my
most house for stability reasons we have
a stance called Derby stance which means
you're basically in a squat the whole
time there's two different kinds of
falling so it's your knees and then you
will eventually fall backward because
that's just what happens so you're gonna
go one two and that's it you just want
to be sure that you don't put your hands
down because your wrists have a tendency
to bring I like to always whenever I
trained hold a box of kittens if you
drop the box of kittens you run them
over and they're dead and your side
[Music]
yes definitely did after falling a
thousand times your body will learn how
to do it safely so mark the more time
you spend on the floor the more you are
a hazard to yourself but mostly others
hazard to myself and others it's like my
byline we're gonna fix that the roller
derby community were super diverse and
were really tightly knit like I would
never have met any of these people
because I'm actually really nervous and
like socially anxious but roller derby
you all bond over like sweating and
falling is something for women that
women didn't think that they could do
because it's something so physical and
it is really violent a lot of what we
get when we first start is I'm sorry
I can't do it I'm not strong enough and
those are all lies you guys are gonna
fall on your ass a lot so we're just
gonna try and get you to have muscle
memory to do it safely so it's called a
slide out your skating your skating
you're like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna fall
backwards right you want to pick a cheap
both be out and off to the side it's
gonna hurt just deal with it well I mean
Paul does have advantages
I'm big but both we go okay that looks
straight down the middle did that hurt
sure did hurt Zach thank you for the
compliment who can you swear at each
other the official ruling is you can
swear in general but you cannot swear at
a specific skater breath or coach so I
can scream I'll [ __ ] on my dick yet I
can't say [ __ ] on your dick yeah just a
general anyone's dick
you always say high on the straight away
and low on the turns that just maximizes
your speed and it gives you more bang
for your buck so you don't have to exert
that much energy to go fast so you go
low in the turn you shoot up on the
straightaway those highs you can shoot
down
again
and no how do you uh skip the track hi
on the street away Jaeger what if going
fast as scary and I don't want to do it
get over it
what if you find that fear always wins
that's why you have had try again try
again guys keep your knees bent getting
a little better
[Music]
[Music]
it's hard to not feel really right now
like I just can't stop I can't play this
sport I don't know what I'm doing this
is super exhausting but per my fiance's
request did not break my face not break
my wrists still I can still walk down
the aisle to hit people but now I'm a
little worried about it like it it's
hard enough just skating what we learned
today was basically equivalent of
running across a football field without
actually doing anything I don't know
what's gonna happen when we actually put
in the strategy the blocking the hitting
and the actual game we don't bomb up
coach now that we're totally dope at
this how do you actually play the game
gather around there are 10 people on the
track there are five from each team we
only have four do you think you could
still win even on a team with us so you
have four blockers and that each team
fields a jammer she's the one who
collects the points so what you do on
the whistle everybody starts moving the
jammers go forward and they try to go
through the pack which is the largest
group of opposing blockers from each
side first one to get out legally is the
lead jammer the second pass is her first
scoring pass and that means every
opposing blockers hips that she passes
with her hips is a point you can't score
points until you've gone round once yes
and that one does around you last 60
seconds or less
how many do you have as many as you can
fit within an hour how do you hit people
with your hips and your shoulder so no
elbows to the face no does it feel good
to knock over a jammer though yeah
what's the worst injury
your face your center of gravity is here
when somebody hits you the lower and the
more grounded you are the better put the
sweet spot to hit is right here oh
that's not fair that's the sweet spot is
so accessible
it is so I would go hop and I would hit
him but I'd pop them up i pop them up
doing it like really enough of these do
Eugene Eugene yeah was that foul yes I
think you guys should work on walling up
what you say walling up yes so it's like
a wall of more people say you get
together chest up eyes up butt down
ready roll out the person on the high
when this case is eugene is gonna go
faster person on the low slows it down
in this straightaway it's the opposite
if you're jean slows down and that fix
it up that is not a wall you've lost a
man if Keith is behind you guys
[Music]
we are given roller derby names
it's basically an alter-ego that
everyone chooses once they start skating
so I'm the hoppers basher what do you
think okay I'll take it she loves it she
loves it she lives there so the
importance of bow makeup it's a way to
pump yourself up some people like to
have the same thing over and over kind
of like a lucky rabbit's foot early you
wear the same underwear yes you help us
put our bow makeup on today in honor of
you being our coach I would love
something horizontal but I want to just
straight across my eyeball all the way
here all the way it's almost like just a
smokey eye but so smoky it's like
volcanic I'm called nasty ned cuz i got
a good bootie and i'm a perfect ten look
back nailed it
what do you think it's printed on the
shirt so we can't change it so I'm
hoping that this look will scare my
opponents from ever wanting to even hurt
me so my last name is yang which rhymes
a lot of fun words I decided to go for
yang bang which describes what I'm gonna
do today I'm gonna bang people so I was
thinking like a fancy man mustache cuz
I'm a fancy nasty man or maybe like
angry eyebrows
my last name is Kornfeld okay so I went
with like you know there's creamed corn
so I'm gonna cream my competition so how
do you think I'm gonna do you've watched
me progress you're gonna be there and
you're gonna do things okay okay okay
okay okay wait oh that I mean
okay if you saw me coming down the track
would you feel bad
hurting me good Oh Jagger you're really
good at Derby but I don't know if you
have a career in makeup does look like I
got run over by a tire on that base yeah
this is awful thank you nasty men ready
for your clown happen do my moustache I
know I look like Daryl Hannan and Blade
Runner I look like one of the Little
Rascals
it's nasty oh hey thank god there's a
teacher nurse and I'm so sorry for the
performance you're about to see
[Music]
try guys on three one two three guys
thirty Seconds to the track
yeah
[Applause]
fine fine so should we have Zach be
jamming our that's exactly what am i
your knees hammer now Jennifer got me to
go fast guys
how'd I do
don't good I thought why the next term
is a power jam which means we are the
only ones who have a jammer and we're
the only ones able to score [ __ ] don't
waste it on me Jean power flake it was
easy go to team and we're gonna try to
not truck it all
[Applause]
roller derby baby I'm really getting
hurt out there
that took some baths go soak my feet
before you get more you're already
confused but I might as well say it so
say Eugene is a pivot right put it on
your helmet but say like I'm a jammer I
can't get out because you guys are so
good at blocking I can actually take off
the panty panda to Eugene take it and
then he now becomes the jammer put it on
top of the helmet double panties oh wow
so I can and then now you or the ski is
just a jammer
I get it I gotcha all right
[Applause]
oh it's falling outside
oh it's hard that's all hurt for this
game
damn [ __ ] baby alright I'm ready to come
out of that penalty box Paul what do I
do
really really fast we believe in you
baby
[Music]
[Music]
hard on the stern around the turn
[Music]
got a good movie and I'm a perfect 10
what my integrity of posture
[Music]
[Music]
wow what a rush you know hard it is to
be on wheels on a really sharp incline
and go slow you think that's a
traditional email thing to like put
yourself in harm's way nope women can do
that just as well they fell just as much
as I thought they would
falling is actually kind of fun very
surprised that no one died there was a
panty path which is always really
exciting Ned got out that was sad not
good teamwork so if these poor guys can
learn how to skate within the last
couple of days go straight into a
scrimmage with the Los Angeles derby
dolls anyone who sees this video can
come look us up find that warrior within
themselves and figure out who you are
through skating
so let's fall in our butts and pretend
like it never happened but Derby roller
derby teaches you how to do it and get
back up and that's a life lesson we can
all take with us male or female
[Music]
[Applause]